hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve
hand of straights so we're given a hand
of
cards which is given to us as an array
of integers so each
card has a particular integer associated
with it
we want to rearrange the cards into
groups so that each group size is a
particular value that we're given as an
input parameter for example one
value we could be given is group size of
three so every group needs to be of
group size three
but not only that every single
group needs to have consecutive
cards in it basically a group could be
let's say
one two three because all values are
consecutive it could also be
2 3 4 right but something like 2
3 5 would not work right because there's
a hole
in here these are not consecutive you
know we're missing a 4
right so one thing to recognize with
this problem is how could we possibly
break it down into groups right like
just looking at this we have so many
different options brute forcing it
is going to be really complex and
there's not really any way to
to eliminate repeated work doing
something like that so we need to find
some kind of pattern
so one thing to notice would be if we
wanted all groups that two could
possibly be a part of we know that one
group could be something like two
three four right because our group size
is three
and this would be if two was in the
first position now it's also possible
that two could be
in the second position right so maybe we
could have a group like one
two three so two could be in a group
where it's the middle value
or it's the first value but notice how
we are always going to have some value
in our input array that's the minimum
value right
one is the minimum value in this case
right so in this case
we could have a group of one two three
right one could be the first value now
are there any other groups that one
could be a part of this is
the only group that one could be a part
of this is what the group would look
like we can't possibly have a group like
one
or zero one two because there's there's
no value that's
less than one we don't have a zero right
so
in a sense we can be greedy we're always
gonna look at whatever the minimum value
available to us is and we're gonna start
with a group
like that right so we're gonna basically
make a group
like this first and we also notice
that yes we could have multiple copies
of the same card so for example we could
have two cards with a value of
two so one convenience thing that we're
gonna probably
do is count the number of each card that
we have right so basically
the best way to do that is going to be
with a hash map right so for each card
for example two we would count you know
two has
two copies in this input array so that's
what we're going to basically do we're
going to use a hash map
to count the number of cards for each
value so like i said we're going to be
taking our input array and then
converting it into a hash map right so
one
occurs one time two occurs two times
three occurs two times and i think you
probably already know how to create a
hashmap like this
and so given that we have a group size
of three what we're going to be doing as
i mentioned is we're always going to be
looking at the minimum value available
to us right
so for example in this case that's gonna
be a one right we're gonna see
can we make a a group size of three
starting at one because we know one
could only possibly belong to one group
and this is what the group
would look like so either we can create
this group
in which case then we're going to
continue our algorithm then we're going
to refine the next minimum value
or if we cannot create this group that
means we can't possibly
put one into a group so we're going to
have to return
false so that's basically what i'm going
to be going over oh and by the way
another quick thing that we could
determine is we
basically need to guarantee that the
size of our input array is divisible by
three right because we need to break
this up into group sizes of three
so it would have to be divisible by
three in this case we have nine elements
nine divided by three that you know
there's no remainder with that so
you know it's possible at least so we're
gonna start at one right
and then we're gonna check okay the next
value that comes after one is a two so
basically we're going to decrement the
count of one right we've already used
our one now we're going to see are there
any twos available to us we can do that
in o of one time because yes we have a
hash map right we can
basically check that instantly so we do
have some twos available to us right
so we're going to decrement the count of
two set it to one
and so far we have a two so now we're
going to look for that last value of
this group right
group size three so what's the next
value going to be we're looking for a
three do we have any available to us
let's check in our hash map yep we have
some threes decrement this count to one
so we were able to create at least one
group
so we created one group now let's see if
we can create another and once again we
are going to be looking at what the
minimum value happens to be available to
us
now the minimum is no longer one right
because we took the count and
decremented it all the way to zero so we
don't have any ones available to us
but we do have a two as the minimum
value available to us
but my question is how can we find these
minimum values
well of course we could just scan
through this hash map right and find the
minimum and we could do that in o of n
time but can we do even better than end
time well we know a data structure
that can efficiently find minimums is a
min heap right so basically what we can
do is add all these
key values from our hash map into a
min heap right so let's say our min heap
initially looks something like
this right so one two three
four six seven and eight right so
clearly we have our minimum at the top
but we know
as we decremented the count of one down
to zero we basically
popped this from our min heap right so
basically what we're going to be doing
is
yes we're going to be popping the
minimum value from our min
heap if the count is decremented down to
zero
so now when we're actually going to be
starting our second group we can find
the minimum value to start out in
log n time we know that each group is
basically going to take group size
to compute so overall what i'm saying
the time complex is mainly going to be
log in multiplied by
n because technically you know the
number of times we pop from the min heap
could be you know whatever the size of
the entire input array happens to be so
this is basically what i'm saying the
time complexity is going to be
but so yes getting the minimum value is
two okay do we have any twos available
to us let's take a look
yes we have at least one two but we're
decrementing the count now
so it's gonna be zero twos remaining so
since we decremented this to zero we
have to make sure we pop from the min
heap right we're popping the minimum
value too okay so now let's look for the
next value what comes after two
of course three so do we have any threes
available to us yes
in the min heap we do have a three
available to us but we're going to be
decrementing its count down to zero now
so once again since three has no more
values left what's the minimum value in
our min heap of course it was three
because we just popped the two
so now we once again have to pop from
the min heap the minimum value which is
three
and last but not least we are going to
get the next value that comes after
three do we have any fours available
yes we do so we're just going to repeat
the exact same process because
we see we're decrementing the count of
four down to zero so once again we can
pop from our min heap we're popping the
minimum value from our min heap of four
so we once again created a group size of
three so now let's see if we can create
one more group size of three so what
let's get the minimum value and we know
we can get that from our min heap now
it's going to be a six so we're going to
start this group at six
are there any sixes available to us yes
there are but we have to decrement its
count down to zero
so basically we're repeating the same
process let's pop that six
from our min heap six is the minimum
value so now let's check
is there a seven available to us there
is a seven
we're decrementing its count to zero
once again we're going to pop seven from
the min heap
the third value we need to complete this
group is going to be 8
and we do have an 8 available to us and
we decrement its count down to 0. so now
we're popping the last
value from our min heap we're popping
the minimum value and it's the last
value
we completed this group so now if we try
to create
a fourth group we're gonna need to get
the minimum value from our min heap but
we
see that there is no value in the min
heap so basically that's how you know we
have no more groups left to create we
basically
you know took every value that was given
to us now let me just quickly go
over a case where we would return false
because
you know in this example we would return
true because clearly we could break it
down but let's say this 8 happened to be
a
9 and you know then the value in our min
heap was also a nine
we were we're looking for an eight to
complete this group but what we're going
to find in our hash map is there is no
eight value
so in that case we can't complete this
group so we would return false there's
another case that we would return
false and let me show you that so let's
say i slightly modified the input array
so i change
one two into a one so instead
so for two we only have one occurrence
of it
for one we in this case have two
occurrences of it so
we're gonna start with the first group
we're gonna get the minimum value it's a
one
so we're gonna start at one we're gonna
take the count of one
and decrement it down to one we're gonna
take the count of two because that's the
next value we're gonna
insert in this group and decrement it
down to zero
now notice how before so basically what
i'm saying now we have to pop two from
our min heap because it's no longer
available
but notice how in the first example
every time we popped from the min heap
we were popping the minimum value
in this case we're popping 2 2 is not
the minimum
value in our min heap and you know
it's usually in min heaps you can't just
pop an arbitrary value you can't just
search for a value in log in time and
then just pop
any particular value you can only pop
the minimum value
so how can we get around this how can i
pop a 2
efficiently in log in time well one
workaround would be instead of using a
min heap you could use
a tree map so in that case you could
search for the minimum value or any
particular value in log
n time and then remove it with a tree
map but that's actually not
necessary in this problem let me show
you why
basically the idea is if we're trying to
pop a value from our min heap
that's not the minimum value we've
already
lost we already cannot break this
up into group sizes and in that case we
would return
false now that's not super intuitive
until you actually run through the
example
take a look what we're doing here
remember how
one is the minimum value available to us
right
and one since one is the minimum value
it could only belong to a group that
looked like
this right so if we're popping a value
such as two or even three
and these values are not the minimum
values we're basically creating a hole
in our in our values right so in this
case
okay two it's it's true that two is
available to us and
three is also available to us right so
we would decrement the count of three
down to one
so we could create one group but when we
try to create the next group now
we're gonna get to a one right and then
we're gonna look for a two but we're
gonna see
that two has a count of zero basically
we were trying to pop a value
that was in the middle of our group so
we can't create another group
because we're missing that two value so
if basically if we
ever try to pop a value from our min
heap
that's not the minimum value that means
we have to return
false because we have a value less than
it that's available to us like 1 but we
don't have that 2
value so we'll never be able to complete
a group
with this one value again so you know we
just have to return false then
so i think that's how we would solve the
problem with a min heap
like i said it's not actually necessary
you could use a tree map if you wanted
and you could actually
not use a data an extra data structure
at all you could just use
i think a sorted input array but i'm
going to be doing it with a min heap
because i like the
way the code works out in that case so
as i mentioned the first thing we do
want to check
is that the length of hand itself is
actually divisible by
the group size if it's not then of
course we won't be able to break this
down so we'll have to return false and
also we do want to create a hashmap
uh counting the occurrences of each
value now i could just use a counter in
python but i usually like to write it
out just in case the interviewer wants
that
so for every value in our hand i'm going
to just
increment the count of n so basically
one plus whatever it was previously
and if it does not exist in our map
we're going to return a default value of
zero
we're also going to be using a min heap
so
we want only the distinct values that
are available to us so what we can do is
take
count dot keys which is going to be
distinct values
convert that into a list which is what
min heaps are implemented as in python
but we actually do have to heapify it so
we're going to do heapify this is a
linear algorithm it just takes an input
array and
transforms it into a min heap now we're
basically going to continue
until our min heap is empty so while min
heap is not empty we're going to get the
minimum value
so we can get the minimum value from a
min heap just at index
zero so min heap at index zero is going
to give us the minimum value
i'm actually going to name this first
just so it's a little bit more
descriptive
and so now we want to see if we can
create a group size starting at first
of size group size so we're going to go
for i in
range starting at the first value right
and
going up until you know the group size
so just add
group size to this so the first thing we
want to check is if this
i value is even available to us so if i
is
not in our hash map then we have to
return
false because the value we're looking
for isn't even available
if it is available then of course we do
have to decrement the count of it so
count
of i is going to be decremented by one
and we do have to check
if this count so if it's now equal to
zero because remember if it's equal to
zero that means we have to pop it from
our min heap
but if we're popping a value from our
min heap that's
not equal to the minimum value in the
min heap which we know we can find at
index 0. so if this is not the minimum
value that we're trying to pop
that means we have to return false
immediately because
if we pop this value if we remove it
then the next
group we're not going to be able to
complete because we know that there is
an
i value smaller than this value so we
won't basically be able to complete the
next group
so we'll just return false immediately
if that's not the case though we are
able
to pop from the min heap we are popping
the minimum value that's easy to do with
a heap so heap q
heap pop from the min heap and so
that's the entire code and if we're able
to get out of this loop we can return
true so if we never execute these two
conditions
basically if a value is is always
available to us
and we're never popping a non-minimum
value
and we never return false in either of
these cases we if we basically break
the hand into group sizes and then at
the end we can return true
so there's many ways to solve this
problem you can use a sorted input array
you can use a tree map or you can use a
heap
all the time complexities of each
solution is going to be n log n
and they all mainly follow similar ideas
so i hope that this was helpful
if it was please like and subscribe it
supports the channel a lot and i'll
hopefully
see you pretty soon thanks for watching